cette charrette c'est tout ce qu'il
reste du geste dramatique qu'a posée
mohamed bouazizi à l'âge de 26 ans dans
la matinée du 17 décembre 2010 le
vendeur de fruits et légumes s'est fait
confisquer tout son matériel par la
police parce qu'il n'avaient pas de
permis en règle
son suicide spectaculaires devant le
siège du gouvernement local avait
ensuite mis le feu aux poudres
[Musique]
des milliers de tunisiens et sa région
avaient envahi les routes et marcher
pendant des jours jusqu'à la capitale
pour dénoncer les injustices dans le
pays
invaincu de lui de ses conneries on veut
qu'ils dégagent les manifestations
monstres avaient finalement forcé le
président ben ali à s'enfuir en arabie
saoudite pour la famille bouazizi cette
révolution a eu également des
conséquences tragiques ou delà de la
mort de mohammed
j'ai pris un taxi et le chauffeur de
taxi il dit que si je trouve à sur wii
un frère ou demorand bouazizi lever le
pied
la famille faisait l'objet de menaces de
la part de partisans de l'ancien régime
ben ali ou encore deux voisins à cause
de jalousie engendrés par la misère
ambiante
la famille avait donc quitté sidi bouzid
pour aller s'installer à tunis
mais l'atmosphère était la même dans la
capitale on les soupçonnait d'avoir
monnayé leur notoriété et un démenti
contre mon île et c'est une juste de
faire des rumeurs comme si nous on a
profité beaucoup de la révolution on a
pris beaucoup d'argent ici ça pour juste
faire une mauvaise image à sion fin 2011
les la la soeur cadette de mohamed
quittent le pays
seul pour montréal visa d'étudiante au
poche
si centre-ville tout est proche et les
épiceries la banque
les centres neige donc ça se pose lui
est très très bien je suis venu ici
comme étudiante étrangère à l'école des
métiers de l'aérospatiale en jeu fini
mon diplôme en 6 et en techniques
d'usinage
après j'ai fait mon stage à chez pratt
whitney canada
et directement acheter engagé j'étais
vraiment chanceuse pendant qu'elle
étudie au canada leila bouazizi
s'inquiète du sort de ses proches restés
en tunisie les lacombe et sa mère de
venir la rejoindre au canada elle
obtient pour elle et d'autres membres de
la famille le statut de réfugié il
s'installe à montréal en 2014
hanafi à wall là où l'assassinât lundi
au du beh oui j'étais vraiment fier va
changer quelque chose dans notre la
situation en tunisie
on peut voter le président qu'on veut on
peut parler on peut
manifeste manifester mais avant on n'a
pas ça pourquoi si bête malheureusement
dit elle le chômage est toujours très
élevé l'économie est très faible il n'y
a pas d'avenir pour les jeunes en
tunisie
et ça me fait mal
[Musique]
sidi bouzid les petits marchands sont
toujours là aujourd'hui
d'autres charette ont remplacé celles de
bois dette bouazizi ce jeune homme avait
entrepris des études universitaires
après la révolution il a dû tout arrêter
et prendre ce travail pour faire vivre
ses parents et ses quatre frères se
cordonnier âgé de 85 ans doit emprunter
de l'argent pour manger la chair ou à la
lumière de ma vie car tout comme mohamed
bouazizi il y a dix ans il n'a pas de
quoi payer son permis commercial
récemment la police a saisi une partie
du matériel pour le 17 décembre ce que
vous faites une petite réunion familiale
non parce que c'est non parce que
c'était un moment très malheureux c'est
surtout ma mère est restée sensible on
ne veut pas que parler beaucoup d'autres
ça ça va les faire mal
même s'ils se disent heureux dans leur
nouvelle vie les membres de la famille
bouazizi sont déchirés un frère et une
soeur sont restés là bas et n'ont pas pu
obtenir le statut de réfugié
un monument un mohamed bouazizi a été
érigé à sidi bouzid
son visage est aussi présent dans
plusieurs lieux publics mais son image
s'est ternie aux yeux de la population y
compris chez les marchands de sidi
bouzid circuit